hey guys this is Eric and I just want to
make a quick video about one of the
games that I played yesterday I played
in the leach s title arena and I
actually played Magnus Carlsen in the
very first game unknowingly and I beat
him so I wanted to share the the stream
footage because I was streaming the
whole the whole event on Twitch and just
wanted to give some background
information before I show that so it was
the first round Carlsen usually plays
under the count doctor drunken Stein but
recently he's been playing under
anonymous accounts to perhaps hide his
identity so people don't don't spam him
on me chess so the very first game I was
playing man with a van who just showed
the Grandmaster title so I thought it
was playing some random Grandmaster it
turned out to be him it was confirmed
via the chest network stream chest
network got7 some inside information
from some me chess moderators now the
one advantage that had actually maybe a
couple advantages I had in the game for
one Carlson was playing on mobile so he
was perhaps a bit slower than normal
maybe the connection wasn't as good and
as you'll see in the game I did end up
having some nice time advantage
especially towards end the second
advantage I had was a bit more
psychological it was the fact that I
didn't know I was playing him I feel
like if I knew I was playing him then it
would have been a lot more difficult to
stay focused but but since I thought I
was just playing just a random player I
was really focused in the game and I
think that brought out some some better
play so I'll go ahead show the footage I
should point out that after after I
played him at some point in the
tournament I was told by the twitch chat
that I did play him and beat him so
you'll see that reaction and then at the
end of the the video I'll I go over the
game reacting to how it transpired so
hope you guys enjoy it okay hello
everyone
it is 1:54 p.m. and the title arena is
started
in just about six minutes if I just
quickly glance it who's playing there's
a lot of players it's over 200 players
Carlson is likely playing except last
tournament he signed up as dr. drunken
Steen and then he switched at the last
minute to an anonymous account so that
was sneaky
and the goal for the the tournament is
to finish in the top let's say 30 that's
a reasonable goal but the ultimate goal
is to play Carlson I don't care about
beating him I just want to play him like
one game never played him in chess
before that I know of deep breath I'm
gonna try and win Colorado and see how
it goes the ice thanks for the bits
don't cheer too much while I play so
they'll be distracting but ok I'm
playing a GM let's play the Budapest
okay he's pre moving too quickly maybe I
can take on the c3 never mind keep the
bishop
yeah I've induced before to play a 5 put
the knight on e5 I just want to be solid
mmm let's take ok maybe I'll attack him
somehow mmm
maybe not
each no I don't know what to do just
have to move around ok 9 f3 and queen g4
looks nice or queen h3 and IG for ideas
III is attacked 2 let's double up mmm
let's see a breakthrough that was a
terrible move playing - slowly - but ok
it's still a fight put the Queen on g6 I
want to take on f4 Knight e3 I can play
rookie 4 mm tricky and just up a pawn
now let's put the rook on the H file
i'll i put the Bishop on c5 block the
rooks put the rook on d6 up some nice
time it's not hangar rook
whoo he hung the rook there okay now
it's usually winning okay that was a
good starts felt like a little bit of
lag but nothing too bad hmm that's
unfortunate
do I really be Karlsson in the first
game no way but is this actually Carlsen
I forget that game I will go back in
time after the stream ends if that
actually happened how did I play him the
first game though she was random he
wants to be sneaky man with Havana so
I'll just go to my profile and do a
search for it
this is a nice tool or no I can just go
to his profile am i doing okay
so if I go to Carlson's profile new name
so he did not play under dr. drunken
steam I guess for two tournaments on the
road now and I go to his games yeah so
we played and I beat him how did this
happen and up I heard he was playing on
mobile but that was just some random
comment I don't know if that's true but
regardless I mean III said before the
tournament my goal was to play Carlsen I
did not have a goal of beating him but I
play them unknowingly I'll have to go
back and watch and see see how it
happened I beat him with a Budapest Oh
cuz he pre moved Knight c3 wow that's so
great so because the the first like
three games I was black I played the
Budapest
so okay you play Queen g1 yeah I've had
this position many times before in Boyd
I might even be like in the opening book
no stronger players and me had played
this too okay so we had some normal
position oh yeah I was happy with this
idea to play Bishop c5 provoked before
and then I can do this break with a five
I had a lesson yesterday with a student
and I was introducing into this very
thematic break Thank You phenomenon for
the 50 bits so anyway I think I played
85 at some points cuz ya know this pawn
has to go away and that gives me more
squares to work with can I scroll down a
little oh you want to see the computer
analysis we'll take a look at computer
analysis after the game because I just
want to look without an engine
especially because it was bullet oh it's
so funny because I like I have very
little memory of what happened next like
if I cover up the notation I don't
really remember how this game transpired
but okay let's see ig6 ah yeah so he
took with the pawn and then I was really
scared for most of this game that the C
pawn was gonna come under fire but that
never quite happened I provoked some
weakness with with g3 no I was just kind
of turtling just holding things together
95 was a nice move ah yeah this is a
moment where it's really hard to stop
Knight g4 so like already given from
this position there's some nice play for
luck you should probably play Queen s1
no between f1 Knight f3 so I have a
feeling like maybe Bishop d3 is already
a mistake and that's hard to see because
forcing line maybe Queenie to is a
better move to allow f4 I'm in some
money that was in 50 bits thanks so much
so Queen do you one okay the computer
says it's dubious I guess Queen h3 I
played Knight g4 and I was feeling
really good here so much pressure rook
e8 9 f6 to take ah yeah that this was
just a terrible move on my parts but
somehow I stayed alive and it felt like
I was getting outplayed and then Queens
got traded and that made me happy and
Bishop yeah Bishop h6 made me really
happy because this is a point that he
can't really defend his pawn if he moves
I take on e3 and if he moves the knight
I'll have rookie for which i think is
very strong so I won the pawn I got the
Bishop to e5 and this is where I was
scared of like rook c1 and b6 or
something but he never went for it maybe
he wanted to play b6 so that's why I
played b6 I was still scared of like
this and then this and then ideas of
rook take b6 so that's why I put my
Bishop on c5 I have a feeling I won this
game on time and not over the board but
let's zoom forward because now this is a
typical like Carlsen grind down where he
just has like a better endgame
oh but I should show the time so let me
make this smaller just a little bit I
have to expand this too because the
times bear with me
yeah The Times should show up right
there if people can see on the side
there yeah so at this point why it had
nine seconds I had 15 seconds so I was
just playing much faster and let's see
how this happened
then he dropped a pawn then I was just a
dirty time scramble where I was just
faster 46 world champion move and then I
won the rook okay
well it wasn't like the most thrilling
oh that was pretty thrilling to like
kind of have a topsy-turvy game was I
think I was better around like Queen h3
and then I played Knight f6 and I just
slipped and I was better again well I
got my Bishop to e5 and then somehow he
outplayed me and yeah that was fun